you know you know you know what really
freaked me out was when john mccain was
on saturday night live
because he was really good he was funny
yeah i was like wow
that's actually good i remember that
that was like that was right before the
election
that was his october surprise oh yeah
i'm hoping i'm hoping trump's october
surprise as he brings corn pop
out porn pop corn
tells his half of the story and it turns
out it's completely different like
like joe biden was sniffing his hair and
just being like
just all horribly unprofessional
lifeguard wait that's trump's locked up
person
that's trump said he's like we have the
great we're bringing out
the great man who needs no introduction
the great
the final piece of we like good purpose
we like
then the final piece of hunter biden's
laptop is like corn pop's contact
information
and they're able to reach out to him and
bring him on stage oh man
you know to be completely honest like
the weirdest thing about the corn pop
story is that it's really obvious joe
biden was terrified of these
these guys right like well yeah they had
they they they got the
the rusty razors the the cement
why why is why is why is joe biden
telling us a story about the one time a
guy threatened him with a knife and he
got scared and apologized
a razor well because he stood out there
with a chain because bill wright
told him that the the the mechanic who
who showed him where all the the
pool filter is dude do people took him
in and he said
he said if you don't you tell you get
that chain that goes across the d pen
and say if you don't get out i'm going
to wrap this around your head and
and if you don't do it then you can't
come back and he was right and so joe
biden went out there
and he he threatened corn pop he
threatened him but also apologized at
the same time he's like
if you i should i shouldn't have called
you esther williams and i'm sorry i i
called did you
did is tucker carlson doing the the
bobby linski thing tonight
i don't know what if like what if but
what if what if the whole big reveal is
that
it the the the the secret documents they
got
was not hunter biden collusion it was
just corn pop
photos of him he's like a friend he's a
friend of the biden family the whole
thing was fake
it was a false flag dude made the whole
story got to find corn pop
corn pop searching for corn pop corn pop
was a good family friend who biden just
threw under the bus
and he's like completely destroyed his
reputation
and now joe biden like now corn pop's
life is over
it's ruined he's like can't get a job
doing anything you want to be you want
to be you
want to be real though i'm willing to
bet the corn pop story wasn't his story
for real right thrill though no oh
yeah i'm willing to bet it like happened
to his friends why would that why is
that the story you'd plagiarize
like i don't get why did he oh no no no
no no no why like why why the first
biden
to ever work not work in coal mines and
go to college when
like that's kind of a noble thing to
discuss that's not even true is it
no no that didn't happen there was a
british politician there was a british
politician who's like why is it that i
am the first in my family to be college
educated my ancestors are working the
coal mines and i was like why did my
family work in the coal mines jack and
then came up and did yeah and i was the
first one to
get to go for to the pool filter um and
it was
it was almost word for word it was like
a per this wasn't like joe biden
plagiarizing some
you know pro-democracy pro-freedom
banality you could hear any politician
say he was drawing from this man's life
experience and family history
uh and but i could understand why
because it was kind of an inspiring
story
why would you make the court like i just
don't get it i hear what you're saying
but it's
you see that johnny carson why about you
about corn pops you see the johnny
carson bit from when i went
we did mention this on the show a couple
days ago whatever but it was a big
scandal that he was plagiarizing and so
johnny carson was like you know joe
biden had to drop out of the race
because he's been
caught plagiarizing and to uh to calm
his staff down he said
don't worry there's nothing to fear but
fear itself yeah i remember that that's
fantastic but
hold on hold on that was four scoring
seven years ago right yes yeah
wait wait wait wait wait you you asked
why did you tell this story and i i i
agree why did he tell us the story but
why did he tell the story about the kids
playing with his hair
in the woods so gross what is wrong with
that that was the same day that was
actually the same it was the same
the same exact hairy legs oh my gosh
did you did you have you ever actually
like listened to the full thing
yeah it's it's crazy i animated the corn
pop store
yeah oh yeah so i did it's like two and
a half minutes
it's it's like or myself and my team
when when grandpa is out of it you know
he's out of it and he's rambling and
you're just like what do we do and
your parents are like just just let him
he's abe simpson yeah
yeah that's true yeah wow dude are we
gonna plagiarizing abe simpson yeah like
his entire persona was lifted off of a
simpsons character
that's something that makes sense did
you see did you see he accidentally
called trump george
that we're getting four more years of
george yeah and so so
well hold on hold on apparently people
are saying that george lopez i guess
was hosting it and so he just mixed up
george and trump george lopez
george bush because he's doing well he
didn't take george bush
george because george lopez was the host
okay
so he thought george lopez was president
i'm kidding he mixed up the names but
the point is
jill was sitting next to him going trump
trump oh my god where's branson
behind every great man is a woman no no
no no no no listen listen
you watch these videos and you see jill
biden and joe
and it's very obvious that we are we are
like on the line between a like
you've got real candidate here and
you've got weekend at biden's here
yeah and you've got that thin line where
jill is standing next to it
you see that that that spoof commercial
they did where it's like a movie trailer
where the guy and this woman come
downstairs and she's like wait a minute
that's our candidate and the election's
a week away
and it's a dead joe biden they weakened
at bernie's him you know i would love to
see
jill biden break down in tears about how
sad she is for joe's
i would feel horrible if that happened
but here's the thing with jill biden
just joe biden specifically let's say he
is actually in perfect mental health
and it just happens to be the case that
he makes these gaps really often
let's just say but let's just say that
that is a possibility
okay that is still not the person you
want leading the free world you don't
want that person negotiating with
foreign leaders you don't want that
person giving speeches
that need to be given in order to
inspire the american people like he's
got to be able to string
some number of words together without
making a serious error
could you imagine if he's sitting like
trump is negotiating historic peace
deals
and he's not like he just i guess he
challenges putin to a push-up contest
no no no no but he's talking to putin
and he goes uh
vlad we gotta uh do a deal with the 700
trillion billion seven thousand uh uh
you know you know spaghetti sauce
he's gonna if this dude can't speak and
he gets names wrongs imagine if putin's
sitting there and then instead of saying
like we're gonna give the us
you know we want you to give the us x
amount of dollars he accidentally says
north korea
oh my god and then they do it they give
north korea the money
and then and then no but then biden
signs a deal and they're like yes
i don't think that could happen there's
got to be fail safes there but that's
still
really funny that's like hysterical
that would be a fantastic film i think i
think the corn pop thing is a press
as like uh decisive like what will
happen if joe biden gets elected
he's gonna be like yeah i'm just gonna
make a big stink and then
wait a minute i gotta be honest yeah
wouldn't it be awesome to get some of
these by like
he's like addressing the nations like
it's like an oval office address
and he's sitting there he's like all
confused his eyes have closed
and then we just get a rambling grandpa
story just like randomly that'd be kind
of fun it's like you're sitting
there you're stressed out from work and
all of a sudden they're like ladies and
gentlemen the president of the
united states of america and he's like
oh you know one time i was going down to
get a loaf of bread and
and then sure enough his corn bob he
comes back and you know he's got his
knife and
he's like what
and so you know i had the bread and and
he sliced it for me
with a rusty razor
on the south side of chicago putting
razors in a rain barrel
like is it was this like one of those
things razors or something like this i
think it was a straight razor
you like you shave with and you'd bang
it on
the rain barrel put it in the rain
barrel what does that mean a curb
you'd get it rusty joe biden i love how
he was discussing this like
as if this was something we should just
all remember doing he's like i remember
he used to put the
the razor don't remember the razor and
the water barrel and
it's like no i never did that joe
actually and i don't i don't think
anyone listening did that either can you
can you imagine as he
he progresses and starts like losing his
filter and then regresses back to like
you know the 1960s i actually feel
really bad for him i don't know how bad
his condition is but
like if it actually is so part of me
thought like he just had a stutter
because that's what the media has been
saying so i was like no i'm totally
kidding he didn't
i'm totally kidding i'm totally kidding
he's not all right now they're saying he
has a structure
when he was a kid biden was famous for
making gaffes for his entire political
career
uh he there was this weird thing that we
saw we saw with clinton we also saw it
with obama where you'd have this
like really articulate uh presidential
candidate and then their vp was just
kind of
a bumbling guy who couldn't say things
about gabs like that was kind of al gore
and and i remember my perception even as
a kid was that joe biden
was just the al gore to barack obama's
bill clinton
uh he's just clumsy and he misspoke
quite frequently
not that he had some kind of stutter and
the media never said he had a stutter
and now that he's making these
ridiculous gaffes in you know
telling stories about uh a corn pop and
his leg hair
i guess they think that's some kind of
impediment when he's speech impediment
like that's how they're trying to play
it off
there was a woman who who said something
about this and
some reporter i'm blanking on who it was
but it was on one of the the mainstream
media outlets like
you're making fun of him how do children
in this country feel when they see you
making fun of him for his
lisp what yeah did you see no no listen
the the issue that concerns me is when
joe biden joe biden
called donald trump abraham lincoln it
was
it was the weirdest thing to me because
he goes abraham lincoln here's the most
racist president we've ever had
and i was like i was like wait wait wait
let me stop it could have been funny my
my brain tried to try to very quickly
decipher this because the first thing
was like
okay my immediate assumption is abraham
lincoln over here george no no
hold on i was like he is he he said
abraham lincoln here is the most racist
president ever had
but then i'm like there's no way he
would call trump abraham lincoln on
stage
is he saying abraham lincoln is the most
right like the actual lincoln
no no they can't be either so you wait
hold on he called trump
abraham lincoln to say this guy talking
about abraham lincoln is the most racist
president trump was trying to talk about
stop stop early on trump said i have
done more for the black community than
perhaps abraham
lincoln for the black community except
perhaps
abraham lincoln
which was also a hilarious moment like i
was sure i was that was dying at that
time
for joe biden to think he is getting
trump by calling him abraham lincoln
was the craziest thing i'd ever heard
he was yeah proceeded over the
beginnings of a civil war so i guess
they weren't saying that
i wish obama had gone fully blinking but
did you no no yeah i've been this few
months before
i bring this up because of trump's
response to being called abraham lincoln
yeah
he loved it he was he was just like they
called me no no listen
he said something like you just called
me abraham lincoln where did that come
from and biden was like uh
or it's like he had nothing to say like
he didn't understand
and trump was like you just called me
abraham lincoln what is this what is
that
and like biden looked crazy yeah he
looked nuts
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you